and though this music has swept the
world with an elevatory vision of our
common Humanity it remains misunderstood
and improperly studied in America we
have yet to consider developing a
general education to illuminate its
mechanics and unlock its power to
transform to this moment not a single
state in the United States requires
students studying to be music teachers
to learn anything about this music
there are many
reasons but the root of it is
historical other
persons are still seen as a ju position
to the National experience instead of a
point of
reference an art that presents meaning
Central to the entire country's
identity it can't come from other
persons that would mean activating a
high quality cultural education capable
of upgrading the national
character other persons have to
downgrade that
character the academy as a
generalization and all of the invasive
commercial media are so deeply committed
to celebrating and selling stereotypes
and social
cliches we're going to need a revolution
in
Vision
sadly America now finds herself
infecting the world with meaningless
commercial products when our finest
documents demonstrate that we are
clearly capable of healing it with the
unlimited
potential of democratic
possibilities